please say a big hello there to tabitha
brown
i can't believe you're here i'm geeking
out
my goodness i'm so excited i can't
believe i'm here
all right tabitha what are we cooking
you ready to eat i am ready to eat i
don't know why but my hips are moving i
don't know what that's about
but when we hungry and we know it's
going to be good and we danced sometimes
that's our best
it's true and the grilled cheese is
truly one of my
very favorite things on planet earth so
i'm
really really excited i love a good
grilled cheese and you know when i want
to
make myself feel like i'm doing
something a little fancy i add my
spinach and my garlic shall we make one
yes and i think your approach to this
honestly is something i've never seen
so teach us tabitha teach us your
brilliance
okay very good okay so first real simple
we take our wheat bread right one slice
let's get a little bit of butter okay
and we're gonna put our butter on the
bread
and we do this for two reasons one so we
can have a like
nice brown toasted look but all
he's in the spinach sticks on to the
butter okay
because we're gonna put it on the
outside so the butter kind of acts as an
adhesive
yeah it's like the glue this is the
outside of the bread so don't put too
much this is the
outside oh did i overdo it i do that in
the kitchen
i overdo it i have no art of subtlety in
the kitchen
the garlic powder on the bread like so
like that
see i would never think to do this
yeah girl okay so then go ahead and we
put it
face down with all your coverings in
your skillet
okay see that and then watch sizzling
go ahead and add your cheese
all right and this is vegan cheese
yeah all right now go ahead and put your
other one on top
all right and we'll get ready to flip it
carefully flip it cheese milk quick
i love it i have such a like support
team here this
is so cool what do you say don't go ruin
nobody's day now can you say it for me
you have to say have yourself a good day
but even if you can't have a good one
don't go messing up nobody else's that's
how i
my daddy always told me that he still
tells me that today he always says that
so i have one that is already finished
do you because
this one the cheese is melted i want you
to i
think mine is good now how do you like
to cut
your bread or do you leave it whole oh
girl no you know we gotta
we have to cut it you know like a little
triangle so make us feel like a kid
again sometimes
this is stunning by the way
okay tabitha how did i do
oh you feel amazing girl look at you
showing off in the kitchen
[Applause]
look this one you dance cause you did it
yeah
come on girl yeah girl that's what we do
yeah can i taste it now
the best part oh god we thank you yes
we're going to taste it amen to that
ready
[Applause]
that garlic powder is so extraordinary
it's such a unique flavor and goes so
well with that i would have never
thought
i might just have to take another bite
that's your business
oh my god tabitha
thank you so much for changing my
perspective on the grilled cheese as
well as life
thank you tabitha i can't help it i
i love you i would love to hang out with
you again
thank you so much for being here
you